it is one of the most prevalent diseases
in the u.s according to the cdc more
than 34 million americans have diabetes
well now in the time of covid those with
diabetes need to be extra careful denise
valdez joins us live in studio with
where nevadans can go for help to
navigate the chronic condition denise
well in clark county approximately 11
percent of adults have been diagnosed
with diabetes but what's really
troubling is there's about 70 thousand
of atoms out there who don't even know
they have diabetes which really does put
them at a greater risk if they get sick
or if they get coveted 19. now every
year about 16 000 adults and kids in our
state are diagnosed with this condition
and experts say don't blame yourself for
developing type 2 it's not caused by
being lazy or you ate too many sweets
it's a genetic condition and certain
factors can trigger it and let's face it
more and more people are becoming
heavier they're developing type 2
diabetes because most jobs require very
little physical activity the nevada
diabetes association urges you to know
your healthy numbers
don't be afraid to get tested you know
when you do have that visit with your
physician
you know do request having the
hba1c test done and that will give you
an indication of whether or not you are
at risk
managing stress and planning your meals
are key so support groups like this one
here really can help we know we bring
this up today because november is
diabetes awareness month so don't do
diabetes alone it's so much easier when
you have a support staff and people kind
of cheering you on a support system the
southern nevada health district does
have free workshops online resources too
so we have a link to both of the groups
that we talked about here on our
healthwatch page at eight newsnow dot
com